ragazzi siamo finalmente arrivati alla
fine di questo video come sempre vi
chiedo di farmi sapere qua sotto quali
sono delle cose che vorreste vedere il
prossimo guglielmo tell è vero che le
chiedo su instagram
ma qualche volta faccia pure un saltino
qua magari esce qualcosa di divertente e
come sempre vi ricordo che se volete
vedere se avete piacere potete
iscrivervi a questo canale ma interni un
bel pollice su per il per aiutarmi a
rilassare i muscoli e niente
scusate ci vediamo domenica prossima con
una nuova puntata di cucina buttata alle
12 ciao
scherzo telefonico io voglio fare
scherzi telefonici e facciamolo ma chi
la mamma ce casca è che cosa dico a cai
una luce diversa dalla tua pronto mamma
fatemi sapere qua sotto se volete che
faccio uno scherzo ma sì che lo vogliono
o fatemi sapere se effettivamente cerco
di convincere se diventa un po brutto
fare gli scherzi telefonici di penn suoi
scherzi nel far chiedere dove sta
chiedendo a chi mangia un cucchiai di
pecorino grattato non è pecorino solo
parmigiano da una vecchia ricetta di
vita non è che è andato a male era
cucchiaino vedono non ho preso un
cucchiaio ha preso un cucchiaio no
arriva un goccio di coca cola ti prego
perché ma qui già pronte va parmigiani
no di certo
a parte questo cucchiaino e la zuppa la
magical mestolo chi è questo colmo deve
essere bello pieno è caduto addosso le
sta chiamando origine ma i big money
making presidente
vabbè dai non era male mangiati una
bella pizza o ci mettiamo
no no sì no non l'ho detto io sono cura
dieta sono stato obbligato
troppe persone ultimamente mi sto
facendo mi assomiglia a jack black nel
video che vuole solo una cosa puglia non
stai più talentuoso può essere anche
quello emotivo per quello di conoscere
un altro particolare grazie mi scrivono
canta una canzone di sanremo ho deciso
di cantare per voi la mia preferita in
assoluto musica
le brutte intenzioni in a ma
l'educazione la tua brutta figura di
ieri sera la tua ingratitudine la tua
arroganza fai ciò che puoi mettendo i
piedi in testa
certo disordine una forma d'arte
ma tu sai solo coltivare nvidia
ringrazia il cielo se su questo palco
rispetto a chi ti ci ha portato dentro
ma questo sono io che succede buco buco
impara a pronunciare ciao mi chiamo
guglielmo in cinese andata specialmente
in questo momento in cui io per
coronavirus sta tirando fuori di una
psicosi collettiva che sfociano il
razzismo più puro che mi fa vergognare
di essere italiano voglio imparare a
dire ciao mi chiamo quegli anni in
cinese e vi auguro di guarire presto
forza motore abilmente se ci sono
bilingue che mi seguono saranno molto
soddisfatti della mia pronuncia né del
traduttore di google si sentiva audio
certo quello che leggo cangi e ciao mi
chiamo guglielmo vi auguro di guarire
presto forza certo sembra il signor
rossi a parlare il cinese
[Musica]
non è comprensibile datemi un voto buono
cade miotto fa una flessione e stando in
verticale ma vomito ce la posso fare
ma qui distruggo tutto concesso tutto il
formaggio e vacui tac tac soprattutto
capire che potenza mi arrivi cerco di
arrivare piano la massa e grandi quindi
anche il calabrone mano massagrande
rispetto alle sue ali eppure la sciabola
rassegna di questa saga su ok
non mi aspetto più niente
mi sono visto distrutta tempore come
abbandonarlo ma che mi ha tenuto e verso
gli appoggi con le brave canzone amico
mi scrivono da rea enrico uno sciroppo
per la tosse idea geniale quel tappo
ferma mai
ci ho messo solo il nativo d'aria
aspetto pulisco io non avrei grossissimi
ruby mentre va bene ma che gli serve lo
sciroppo per la tosse allora palude o un
gatto perché è a base di zuccheri nano
tutti i cristalli di zucchero e
settimane di saccarosio ho risposto
abbastanza non è che è la bavetta del
nonno ti prendo la misura pala l'occhio
per dimetto
basta che fa vedere a tutti che vuoi
curarti l'è preso tutto quanto tutto
aspetta fatti raccogliere c'era colto
mendola
si scrivono ombre cinesi
io non soffre cinesi ma va bene
facciamolo questa è quella colomba non
mio ma non è uno share del lo struzzo
che bella paura il coniglio l'occhio che
scruta cosa facciamo delle immagini e
bisogna indovinare che cosa sono cos'è
questo gianmarco tu cosa proprio dico
immagine ma cosa stai cercando di fare
il pisello
non è facile il bene mio arrivo è bene
non il tuo fare uno scherzo telefonico a
lui giancola basta tipo quelli che
chiamano le pizzerie i numeri a caso le
vecchie tre anni per un coma che è
pronto veramente sono l'unica persona
che si mette imbarazzo quando vede
persone e fare scherzi ad altri i the
show i riccioli adoro inizia a vedere i
loro video ma io l'ho detto pure allora
un po mi fermo meno sono pazzi noi lo
fanno delle cose geniali ma che a me io
mi imbarazzo e anche per loro c'è una
volta volo si è fatto il bagno dentro il
bagno di un bar con quello che è entrato
e vedeva questo che aveva una piscina
d'acqua
scriviamo sottoli delle show bravi da
guglielmo perché io non farei mai a fare
un loro video mai legge il passo di un
libro a caso tipo vangelo vediamo che
cosa sceglierà radar occhi chiusi e
aspetta scritto col mio sangue
un libro di una bellezza assurda irene
vilar ragazzi è fortissimo apriamo a
caso ok ho sentito leggi delle leggi di
getto
mamma mia ragazzi questa è pesantissima
in ogni campo grande forza questo
principe nero di hollywood
walt disney bompiani con il successo dei
tre porcellini fu disney ad avere la
soddisfazione di salire alla ribalta
3 fai una donazione a un'associazione
causa che ti sta a cuore io in realtà
già un po di beneficenza mensile
progetto da me non è mai troppa questo
qui è il mese quale stiamo veramente
appoggiando la stazione artisti ski team
siamo andati ospiti la loro a vedere
cosa fanno con i bambini con disabilità
per dare loro la possibilità di trovare
una vocazione del campo degli sport
invernali
se non avete visto il video vi metto qui
un link alla scorsa puntata del blog
settimanale dona ora nast tramite iban
in porto segreto donazione per il motel
se volete farlo anche voi scrivete due
razze neve guglielmo tell che se non è
molto carino ha confermato un milione un
milione e lo so ne guadagno così tanti
uno in più nemmeno prova a tradurre una
versione di greco e vedere quanto ti
ricordi
ricordo un cavolo di greco tra gli
uomini cacano in scenari di tornato in
casa
no no no organizzarmi un appuntamento
un appuntamento lo potete trovare su
instagram tassa con due esse le
alessandro tassone un ragazzo in forma
super in forma non ha spiegato altro non
so quindi che tipo di persona cerchi nel
dubbio buttatemi ceduti nel senso la
fortuna aiuta gli audaci io posso
solamente fare fino a un certo punto è
dare una mano fino a un certo punto
scatenatevi come delle oche giulive la
mia coach di pallavolo mi dice fai la
storia è vero queste cose devo fare da
un po di tempo quindi la faccio adesso
io faccio parte di una squadra di
pallavolo amatoriale un misto stiamo
cercando ragazze o allora voi foste di
roma nord
avreste voglia di giocare in squadra con
me e con altri ragazzi un livello medio
di misto scrivete non a me ma a f5s o su
instagram è lei con un gatto federica mi
aspetto giocatrici donne di uomini ed è
solamente troppi capri instagram e prova
a ricreare la prima foto che compare
nella home
dobbiamo creare una parvenza di pizza
tonda tentiamo i buchi i buchi
scrivono menare la regia qui mi scrivono
il test su quali principessa 6
secondo me sono ariel aurora perché
collerico il tuo look posso sembrare
dismessa ma quando voglio mi trasformo
chissà se sarà semplice ma raffinato
confortevole ma allo stesso tempo
sensuale sempre diverso a seconda
dell'occasione sempre di prima e
cenerentola successo e poi voto bordj
bou said fra le opzioni dove sei un roi
top come dovrebbe essere il tuo principe
azzurro che domande deve essere il
principe azzurro 20 quella ok
affascinante e misteriosa il segreto di
una relazione che funziona condividere
avventure e disavventure saper
affrontare le difficoltà insieme
imparare a conoscersi davvero che acer
si da subito
sono molto molto molto molto molto
superficiale non lo dirò mai il tuo
weekend ideale a casa finalmente posso
leggere tutti i libri che voglio è
questa e una con gli amici a ballare oa
bere qualcosa insieme provare qualcosa
di nuovo
poi non mi ha mai o leggere un buon
libro di camere sono tutti quanti libri
è bella che legge sempre nella vita
quella se non stare insieme però è
quella che dovrebbe purifica realmente
figlio è la cosa migliore ed è quella
che è andata meglio di tutti secondo me
l'avete ma anche da biondino quando fa
gaston hall non so che di sexy ma
veramente alto spessore è infinito fammi
finire ragazzi tanto deve montare veloce
test e dica che non hanno imparato
ancora come si monta sei bella vabbè
hanno fatto stampa schiaffeggia
gianmarco d'obbligo enrico mangiare dal
tuo stesso piatto
piuttosto si toglierebbe la vita ma
certo queste le zone comunque che
vogliono infatti che mai e non di lui è
come quelli come fanno già il parmigiano
a meno che vogliono far mangiare un
nuova gianmarco avevo mai avere
parmigiano come mangiare dal mio piatto
è divertente semplicemente vedere le
persone che si schifano per delle
cazzate tipo etico che non mangiare
piatti degli altri è totalmente alle 1
vai paura allora le cattiva luce
ma perchè non fai questo e arrivato il
tuo commento di recarmi la luce legami
tullo cioè e poi patetiche le verdure
vangelo del tuo studiato canta una
canzone rap
scegli tu quale enrico t o disfatto
mangia danno piatti enrico se in deriva
gusta la mia saliva a commenta gli
outfit degli oscar
bene allora qui c'è una natalie portman
bellissima sauron sono tuo padre
immagina con una maschera uma thurman il
mio grasso matrimonio greco
lei si è vestita da oscar ma le scarpe
argentate scarpe argentate concorso
d'oro
mi sa che pacchiana e ne è fiera jack
sparrow
guardate che nicole kidman bestie dal
buio
dopo il successo della scorsa puntata
ecco a voi il ritorno di un nuovo
guglielmo tell come sempre su instagram
e ti ho chiesto di farmi sapere che cosa
avrei potuto fare a casa mia da solo
così e miseria di un pochino di spunti
telefono alla mano è arrivato il momento
di fare quello che mi è stato suggerito
da tre persone che mi seguono